what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation Greg here today I'm going
to react to the trailer number dose for
Dune part dos I saw the first one uh
three times in the theaters I am so
excited for the ultimate IMAX experience
for part two so ladies and gentlemen if
you could sand worm right over I don't
know I was trying to make that work it
wasn't like but I'm saying the like
button thing you said please go ahead
and do that for those wondering Hey
where's your trailer reaction co-host
John well uh I don't know I called him
five times you should know by now if
you're a follower of this channel that's
how it goes alrighty let's get to it
[Music]
world is beyond cruelty
you've been fighting the Harkins for
decades
unless family's been fighting them for
centuries this is so good to be back
here they were massacred
this Bleak ass World there
my father didn't believe in Revenge
we believe in fremit when we fight
beside you
reload
hell yeah
[Music]
who doesn't love Zendaya man
he said I got that
thanks
[Music]
I won't be fighting for him
I'm fighting for my people
do you believe him
better science
guys
Goosebumps everywhere why is that a bad
thing use it
because all my Visions lead to horror
because you lose control because I gain
it
what a great cautionary life
Paula trades are still alive
oh
Dawn
with this profit
your father
was a weak man Ah that's not what you
want to see
look who's back from the dead
no do it must be done
we gave them something to hope for
that's not home
a great mirroring shot as long as I
breathe
this prophecy is
prophecy
story I don't care what you believe I
believe
oh boy
a [__] great does this look man
[Music]
destroy a thing has the real control
with it
[Music]
God I am loving I am I mean there's so
much to look forward to with this movie
but one of the things I'm absolutely
loving about especially with this
trailer
Timothy shalloway man he was so much
more like restrained in the first movie
you know he's given like a real um
internal subdued performance here all
that like darkness and rage is just
simmering and and just rising to the
surface he looks so powerful here I love
how this is so much a reflection this
entire trailer just his descent his
descent and Ascension in both into like
power and darkness seeing him say lines
like long live the fighter and he who
can destroy a thing has the real control
of it they were just hitting home so
much because so much of like Paula
trady's character is there like a
reflection or a study of power Destiny
and and Humanity overall after watching
the setup where you have all this like
good political and religious Intrigue
with him here we get to see him go full
blown with these like astronomical
abilities showcase even more how much of
a strategist he is but also get to see
him fully form into a leader for walking
especially because you know like
Christopher walk into someone something
of a meme himself but you could tell
he's given his gravit toss here he's
he's committed to giving a dramatic
performance and just in his little
glimpses that you get of him you could
feel he is a shrewd character cunning
side that ruthless side everything about
his presence on screen too it just left
an impact and you know of course you
know getting to see more of Zendaya
chani is her name and getting to see
more of her character here which I I
liked every Glimpse that we got as well
because it feels like such a great
demonstration of strength and resilience
getting to see her skill set while
submerged into Warfare so I feel like
it's really gonna pay off super well
after everything we wanted to see from
her in part one and now we're gonna see
it all brought to life here in part two
but also the conflicts that she's going
to run into with Paul here I feel like
her and Timothy chalamet are going to
have some great scene work together and
also you know we got more of T you know
so you know we got more teases of Dave
Bautista I'm looking forward to seeing a
little bit more of his cruel and brutish
side seems like there's gonna be
something real personal there with him
and Gurney Gurney's back Gurney's back
too kind of wish they reserved that
scene where they reunite even though we
all knew he was coming back I kind of
wish they reserved that scene for when
I'm watching it for the first time but
you know and they they got to do their
marketing and Josh Brolin's a household
name so I enjoyed seeing that and he I
love I love the updated look but just
overall I thought the trailer was
genuinely great so much of here focused
on the the concept of you know prophecy
versus story predestinations and
mysticisms versus something real or
imagined the conflicts that come into
hand with a belief system and how that
affects it and what's real and what
isn't real overall you know as someone
who loves just strong visuals I am so
beyond excited for this because I
believe this entire movie was fully shot
in IMAX and I forget the actual numbers
of things but like I'm an IMAX
Enthusiast and like out here in Los
Angeles there's a bunch of iMac screens
but there's very few that are at the
that are considered real IMAX like
there's one at Universal CityWalk where
if you go to like an IMAX down the
street from Universal CityWalk you see
such a vast difference in scope and size
and I feel like this movie is truly
taking advantage of using those IMAX
cameras and will really get to immerse
you into that scope and size the last
one they did have a marketing with it
where they probably led a lot of people
into thinking that there's going to be a
little bit more action than the movie
actually delivered still a lot of people
really love that film which is really
cool to see because it's mainly you know
story and setup for what's to come for
here and I feel like here is where you
get this big cathartic payoff for
everything that's going to be happening
because the action looks incredible the
visuals are incredible this just feels
like so war-torn and weary and battle
heavy uh and it just feels so goddamn
exciting so yeah guys I'm really excited
for Doom part two I I can't wait to
watch this what did you guys think about
this second trailer leave your thoughts
down below be sure to leave a like
subscribe and last but not least before
we go let's end this with a pic
Ricardo Martinez Ricardo I want to say
thank you so much for um being a part of
our patreon page for so long uh if
there's anyone at our patreon page who I
would follow into battle who would be
the Paul the tradies of our patreon page
well at 100 would be you you're the only
one at our patreon who has experience in
the military you you are a veteran
yourself so yeah I mean it just
logically makes sense that
there's no one else I'm gonna follow him
and about you're the only one who I feel
like we would have strategist abilities
and we would really know how to lead and
guide so
thank you thank you you'll keep us safe
and I appreciate you for keeping us safe
at all times and for always looking out
for us and being one of the best members
of the best citizens of the reject
Nation ever and more than that you're a
super sexy reject Ricardo thank you
buddy for always dropping a good comment
our way and for just being an ultimate
supporter in our life I can't wait to
follow you into battle and watch you
ride a sandworm my friend
[Music]